welcome to the civilian plate collie
[ __ ] from Austria it is always playing
the Benoni strangely enough yeah with
only a sixth sense is also funny it
prevents any Bishop b5 ideas but still
it feels strange to me that you can
spend all this all this moves okay I'm
going to play aggressively and see what
happens
Wow
yes well as you know probably I'm a very
classical player and it seems weird to
me that you could actually afford all
this but maybe you can play a six and
the law white pawns to d5 and e5 okay if
I take and give this check on e2 is he
going to play Queen to chat 7
or King a bit
yeah probably Queenie seven and that's
this would drag his King into the middle
of the board okay so Jack sport castling
rights it's got rupee eight though rupee
aid and King evade so how to how to play
this
yeah rupee a this is a point ok I'm
going to complete try to complete
development there should be three and
short castles King fasl hats.night you
for so check going to do another
exchange share so should I go what about
f5 is that five an idea intending a
quick Bishop f4 okay not not spending a
jcm night h42 and take f5 this is even
more interesting yeah this is not even
more interesting it's just better for
white if he goes yeah I can just I can
just retreat it he has no way to protect
f5 and the night landing on earth hi
this is a major thing it's just a
fantastic square attacking d6 and you
were so play so nicely positioned there
it cannot be driven away and i also have
c3 this is important to block his bishop
i haven't played c4 yet or anything his
only recount to play possibly is against
the d5 pawn but um don't see him how at
the moment yeah this is pretty good
setup trying to position this night at
this Bishop actively
should 2f form if it takes me 2 i've got
rope be one loop b7 activating and if he
takes Knight eggs this is or
everything's fine the bishop only five
versus best piece so this is the one I
need to to combat at least them combat
and yeah most urgently you need to play
against all your opponent's pieces of
course but this was the most urgent
thing to do okay how to continue now he
played f6
maybe you look you one but you'll miss
the King anyway c3 this may be Knight b6
attacking the pawn I can also just take
hmm okay yeah it's um i would like to
invest a bit of time to play it
precisely but it's also important to not
fall so much behind on the clock this is
some simple and probably good
ok
let's protect protect my important porn
intending to take with the rook if he
captures attacking the night there
wasn't sure what's the best way we
didn't want to spend too much time I
also try to play Knight c3 getting rid
of his night yes this one yeah I'm not
sure should I play d4 but its advanced
even King g5
check
I don't don't know how to do that Knight
to c6 sounds not really helping 93 s
also not I'm not great
check I don't really want to draw here
but I somewhere lost and threat I wonder
I wonder where my mistake was okay but
still need to continue here
yeah he's a ticking see for now and I'm
down on the clock hmm what the heck I
went wrong them I don't really
understand
Knight b6 is even stronger now this was
suppose if I want to move in night f12
III this will happen at least some idea
to protect to protect the sea football
in trying to activate the root cannot
use the be fine at all now the night is
bad on c6 and I said it myself that it
is bad I still put it down sometimes you
really wonder what time morning what the
heck were you thinking
maybe maybe I can do something the a5
chess is also week check check this is
very recently what I'm doing here black4
fits on time hmm yeah I have no idea
what what the position is I just wanted
to to fight here but I can i can take c
for ya he can take c phone this is this
is fine night f and I just afford to
play f3 yeah so I'm were seeing that I'd
really really didn't know what was going
on but what the heck it was computers
completely busted and I didn't I didn't
really have managed to to do that to do
am I had to do something with it night
g3 is the movement yeah computers are
really strong HS not exactly a new a
newer rather kind of Revelation but
night g3 is really strong it attacks the
you for night this is excellent hmm
guide if he takes down at the end that's
really d6 hanging and I just win this
pawn so this was the Kia there was some
I mean this should should keep something
as well but wow I you don't see yeah
maybe yeah the computer points out night
f form this is again an interesting
pretending 96 and capturing is very bad
okay not not too much this is really am
here starting here and playing like this
like a real [ __ ] getting chatting
he was ready to go okay but I didn't
want to draw on put but in the process I
really wasn't my position considerably i
actually knew that the light is bad
there yeah okay sometimes you really
just should be ok with the drawn all
right thanks for watching